[Applause]
hi paradise hi drew how are you
i uh i'm ready to get into this tell me
everything
cool so this is my take on everyone's
fast food favorite you know crunchwrap
supreme
i mean does everybody know what a
crunchwrap supreme is i think you do
but maybe for those who don't know
what is it what is it faraday i mean
it's basically
all of your favorite things that might
go into like a taco or burrito
wrapped up in a nice little tortilla
with a tostada in between
making it super crunchy delicious kind
of fresh you know
why not um okay so you're gonna keep
cooking
yeah and then i'm gonna keep checking in
and we're gonna make this at some point
in the show
let's do it but you'll be here i'll be
here okay that is so cool
all right because it already smells
amazing okay cool so this is my take on
everyone's fast food favorite you know
crunchwrap supreme
um we've got our ground beef kind of all
going it's seasoned what we can do is
we've got
queso here i noticed do you love queso
on a double boiler
on a double boiler so a double boiler is
basically water underneath
it's you know a heat proof bowl we're
going to add in some
pickled jalapenos and so this is how
this
this uh queso is so good it's so easy
it's got a mixture of velveeta and
oaxacan cheese some milk and those
pickled jalapenos
and wahaka cheese it's from you know the
oaxaca region of
mexico if you didn't have that at home
you could totally get mozzarella cheese
or something like that it's fine
um but then yeah and then in our our
ground beef
it's all kinds of different seasonings
in there we're going to assemble these
though because i think that we're
basically
ready to go so we've got our ground beef
this i mean the whole studio smells
amazing right now if i do say so myself
um we're gonna put a little bit just in
the middle of this so because
essentially what we're gonna do is
we're building up like a bunch of
different things onto here it's almost
like
a bunch of like taco fixings
on this it does smell like the best taco
night i've ever been to
i mean and the seasoning for this
everyone always gets the packets of taco
seasoning
you can make that so easily on your own
you just use
garlic i mean there's all these things
right here there's ground cumin there's
ground coriander paprika cayenne garlic
powder and onion powder
on top of this we're gonna start with
adding a little bit of
our queso right on top of this with the
pickled jalapeno
okay on top of that we're gonna do a
tostada
and that's what makes it the crunchwrap
right this is what makes it the
crunchwrap yeah and then also we're
gonna pan fry it and it's gonna get even
crunchier as you pan fry it so
right in the middle there and then on
top of that we're going to do
some sour cream now also i know i feel
like tostadas are one of those things
that are kind of hard for people to find
a lot of places but if you don't have
tostadas you could use
doritos my parents who don't really cook
a lot of my recipes
and don't eat a lot of fast food either
made this recipe and they used potato
chips
so you can get that crunch in a lot of
different ways potato chips um
fritos you could use fritos for sure
um we're gonna add a little bit of
tomato on top
look i mean this is kind of like a
little salad you know and the
sour cream is like a glue which works
well exactly
we're going to do some lettuce as well
you are going for it with all this stuff
and i love it i'm watching you
i know i might be crazy too big no go
big or go home right okay
it's good yeah and then this little more
cheese more cheese on top
also i wish that we could see your dog
back here who is like
just waiting waiting so patiently
he's like he's like no he's like this is
douglas's inner dialogue right now
something falls something falls
something yeah exactly paul something
fall
yeah you'll get it you'll get it all
right um we're gonna do
one of these little yeah you're ready
for it but one of the little ones yeah
right there okay this is where it gets
tricky okay
okay we've got our pans eating before we
even do that let's add a little bit of
oil to our pan
so we've got a nice hot pan over here so
you ready to do the fold yes okay this
is literally the trickiest part okay
okay you're gonna fold one little piece
up okay and then you're gonna pleat it
so
you're gonna do a little pinch like that
another little pinch like this and you
have to hold it the whole time with your
little thingies right there
and yes i did that's correct
oh my gosh this is this is where it gets
a little intense we're gonna
so put your hand kind of here and you
need to like we're going to flip this
like that
and gently very carefully because you
want to
like do it seam side down to seal it all
in
so right in there i like to give it a
little twirl
moving around there look at that
okay like this couldn't be easier all
right i'm gonna turn my heat up a teensy
bit
i mean this is pretty good what kind of
i mean are you ever doing taco night
with your kids
um i do do tacos with the girls
and um they like i i got them into like
rice and beans really young
yeah um and they love guacamole and
chips that's
like
uh yeah now i i
[Music]
okay it needs to turn no matter what
flipper
oh well all right here's the good news
mine's popping open a little bit too
it's all right it's
it's the right pleading it's the wrong
sear
see look at faraday's gosh darn it
[Laughter]
i burnt the bottom when we were you know
chatting away
oh and you do so it's still gonna taste
good though
you know what i mean come on it's gone
all right at least i got the pleating
right here i'm gonna cut mine open and
we're gonna yeah i'm also just gonna
do that look at this that looks good
right
oh yeah hold on here we go ready wait
wait for it listen
oh it's really fun to cut through
because it's like
going going crunch going going okay
look inside oh beautiful right
look at that and you know what's inside
this
you did it all yourself cheers cheers
turn around
yeah i mean it tastes like i haven't had
one of these in a long time
and it's so good oh my god this is so
good
let me just try one more right it's
crunchy it's cheesy velvet all over
what look at that
describe it